snitch on the toast but on bum snitch on
the toast a snitch on the show spit on
bum snitch on the toast Wow Wow this is
our last time seeing that for a long
time I am depressed no it's really sad
nothing gives me like you can take a
shot of espresso or you could sing
snitch on the toast
shot of espresso or a sing Saanich on
the toast and both will give you the
same amount of energy enough to do a
morning show with snitch on the toast
welcome snatcher thanks for having me
I'm so excited to be back got it again
with you back at it again uh it's been a
great weekend yeah very relaxing weekend
yeah it's been it's been feels like it's
been a long time since I've been here
shares oh yeah she's been gone for a
year she's been gone for a really long
time she will be back tomorrow she is on
her way home from Morocco I can't wait
to hear all about it I know I can't
believe she was in Morocco it's just
like so far away it's so far away she's
a long journey ahead of her and I hope
it is not treacherous probably knowing
us how are you I'm good I'm feeling
great I did absolutely nothing this
weekend I'd love to hear it and I just
slept and it felt amazing and necessary
so you're a rejuvenated snitch yeah
except I couldn't fall asleep last night
so not that rejuvenated but whatever
that's always how it happens
I had a relaxing weekend as well I did a
lot of nothing just like with a new
backdrop that's nice I'll have a change
of scenery
Zak and I went out to Montauk for the
weekend and it was so beautiful like it
was freezing but it was beautiful you
know yeah reason they have a lot of
outdoor fireplaces so we were able to
like sit outside and be toasty
did you enjoy the snow this weekend okay
counselor snitch someone in my elevator
told me it was gonna snow this weekend
probably oh no and then she comes in and
she's like it's supposed to snow this
weekend I'm gonna go to the Hamptons and
I was like okay and then I checked the
weather and instead is supposed to snow
on Tuesday and jury's still out on that
jury's still out but I'm having
flashbacks because it was this week last
year when it snowed prematurely in New
York causing the divine diversion which
I learned happened because when it snows
this early not all the leaves have
fallen off of the trees so when the snow
hits the trees the trees become too
heavy and they start to snap they snap
the rest of it ass they said the seal to
kawari they steel to cope hurry they
snap the wrist of the trees then the
trees be
cause roadblocks and that's what caused
all that crazy traffic and mayhem
guardia was closed because the trees
couldn't handle the snow which is why
it's actually bad if it snows this week
and it could be dividing the version 2.0
and it's like I had the same situation
as last year where we're flying back
from Nashville and the next day I'm
going somewhere else but if I miss if
that flight doesn't happen on Thursday
I'm screwed
you'd think maybe you'd learn from your
mistakes well maybe the weather could
learn from its mistakes and stop
snapping trees well maybe that's not how
life works and you're supposed to learn
from your mistakes maybe you know what I
actually gonna learn from my mistakes
where I'm gonna pack for the next trip
just in case I have to go straight from
Nashville to LA Wow but like that's a
lot I know but like I guess a lot Rachel
thanks a lot you idiot
anyways that's well we'll see how that
goes this week if we had divine
diversion the sequel though I wouldn't
hate it because the divine diversion is
just such an iconic film oh yeah I mean
I feel like every time fighting out of
Nashville there's an issue because I had
one too yeah do you wanna hear something
so crazy when Zack and I were talking
back yesterday I was talking about how I
was having flashbacks to last year's sue
vine version you were just like having
PS right because we were talking about
the weather and the trees snapping and
he was like what's that and I was like
the divine diversion he was like do you
just make that up I was like the divine
version what and he was like no what do
you mean I was like when we were
diverted to Pittsburgh he was like you
think it sounds kind of familiar oh my
god I was like well I was late to a
weekend with you so I'm glad you don't
remember it because tension sweating
well yeah but I'm glad it didn't make it
like such an impact as I missed like his
friends rehearsal dinner because of the
diversion oh yeah but I'm glad he
remembers I'm glad he's paying attention
yeah pay attention please well it's
gonna be such a busy week the next two
weeks are so busy and it's really like I
feel like I work in corporate America
because the holidays are always so busy
for the holidays are so it's for worker
bees and this time of year is just so
busy for us so this week is gonna be
crazy tomorrow quads back we're doing a
show we have a special guest it's gonna
be awesome
Wednesday will be podcast only episode
Thursday no episode because we are
traveling and praying to God that we're
not diverted and Friday we are back in
the studio so it's gonna be a great week
Wow I believe you're only missing one
and then of course on Wednesday it's the
CMA Awards we're going live from the red
carpet like I'm so [ __ ] excited and
I'm so nervous
oh my god like I honestly like for the
first time in my life I don't envy you
like I'm so excited to be a spectator
like I genuinely wouldn't be able to do
what you're about to do and I know
you've already done it twice but even
still like I just couldn't do it so I'm
just really excited to be like home
looking like a schlub just like watching
my sister's thrive and then enjoying it
it's so jealous of you
like I just I could never do what you're
doing you would think I mean I can't do
what I'm doing even think because we've
done it twice before like it should get
easier but no it only gets harder the
stakes only get higher because the last
two streams have been like incredible
and I'm just so nervous that my dress is
so tight so it's like on top of
everything else I'm gonna have to be
sucking in and like paying attention to
my arm oh that's the worst like that
you're just I can't like like I said
first time in my life don't envy you
yeah but I don't you're bored like
you're gonna get so many Marie Lu combs
you just dropped an album on Friday I
told you that I wasn't ready to talk
about the album until I had time to live
with it and I'm happy that I've lived
with it we listen to it on the way there
and on the way back from Montauk and
it's just incredible anyone is act like
it you know what Zack was being like
really annoying about it and like he
started in with like the Olsen with Sam
and I was like don't go there don't go
there and then we put on Jesus is king
no so like we were we were having like
an album and like an album drive and
then we listened to a golden hour and
it's just still like the most incredible
album I was actually listening to Golden
Hour recently for the first time in like
a while and I was like holy [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] slaps yeah and he was he
loves Golden Hour so I used it as a
segue to put on him pageant material
album and he didn't even notice oh no
pageant material is so different than
gold so different but we've got our
track cuz I still wanna talk about we
have to talk about Luke Holmes what are
some of your early favorite songs even
though they're all incredible it's like
it feels rude to choose one right so all
I'm gonna choose it's like this songs
that I've gotten stuck in my head
because that's a sign of like a great
song okay
I'm learning some new every day
that has been stuck in my head since the
album came out like I don't know why and
also does to me
good brother a damn good brother and
also when he's like um oh [ __ ] I just
had the line when he was like I stand up
for what I believe like hey speaking of
standing up for what we believe thank
you to all of the military veterans and
everyone who is currently serving in our
armed forces
today's Veterans Day so please take a
military person because they are the
reason why we got to sit here and just
talk nonsense on the show every day for
an hour thank you thank you for your
service thank you for your service um
Luke Holmes what else okay better
together like I think that that song
like just might be one of his best songs
ever it's like a beautiful crazy like
it's just gonna oh you think so it's
like I think it's gonna be like number
one and it's like the song that's
charting the the highest on country yeah
snatcher with the interests on staff
yeah like it was number three overall
all weekend and obviously it's been
album has been number one overall all
weekend which is just apparently it's
like the first country album to debut at
number one that genre crazy that that's
never happened I know I always like read
these statistics I'm like you sure but
that can't be right
totally I totally like Cappy wooden
posted on his Instagram before and true
you know Kathy it's not a lie or not
he's not [ __ ] around no but also all
over again yeah I love but also reasons
reasons that the reason oh my god I just
every song it's like his lyrics are just
like I can't with his lyrics make they
just are so logical and makes so much
sense but so good too yeah so so many
times I listen to all over again and I
thought the whole time it was about
falling in love all over again but it's
not it's about sometimes I fell in love
all over again but then they also break
up all over again a hundred times I only
got that this morning because there's so
much complexity so many meanings so much
complexity I honestly feel bad for
anyone who or at least new music on
Friday because I did not get the you
know who gotten the story I'm the
mistake well she got to perform her new
song last night at the PCAs and while I
love the message of the song it's like I
don't want to go to the club like I
don't have to go to your [ __ ]
club I relate to it on the deeply deeply
personal level and she's like wearing
that transfers I'd say we're you jealous
of the dress I was so jealous of the try
said and she's singing like a song that
is chemistry
for mine from my soul but like it
doesn't hold a candle to Luke oh right
right you know it's it's just totally
different yeah and I think it's it's
meant to be yeah different he's
performing at the CMAs though and I'm so
excited I think he's gonna sing whoo
maybe one too many like some one of his
new mice or even what we'll see is what
you get or even though really he
performs around Jimmy Fallon right
because that's and he released it to
country radio as a single and also crazy
Mets performed it so like he needs to
fix it but he also release it at Heat
it's his newest single okay I don't
listen to like country radio so I don't
even know what no I don't know that I
just follow him and he relates to
country radio he told us yeah okay well
I hope he performs that so that I can
cry all my yeah I was gonna say it's
like what's the point we got I dressed
up then yeah oh so blue-collar boys is
um is banger all of them there's
literally not one skip act the only
things that I do scape are the songs I
already knew because I want to I want to
educate myself with that with the new
ones
yeah it's just I'm so glad that we have
this album I can't wait to talk to him
and Nico on the red carpet
what's up they're so [ __ ] cute I just
I just love the cheese in everything I
can feel her presence in all of herself
oh my god when I'm listening to
something like I see her face I see her
face and then I also actually legit my
see her face on Spotify I never like
watch that stuff that I saw that he put
out like a special album for Spotify
he's also got a music partnerships every
music partnership but it's not just that
like the new thing on Spotify is like
what a song plays there's just kind of a
boomerang playing in the back yeah so
the songs that are about hurts
boomerangs of Evette which is I'm glad
for it on this album but in general I
don't like it because it takes up like
it uses your battery like I will leave
my phone playing while I do my makeup
and I'm watching music videos it's like
I didn't sign up for a battery usage
that's just what it is like every right
now but yes he's getting every
partnership he like he's literally the
next Garth Brooks it's the craziest
thing it's the craziest thing he can do
no wrong and I just I love them I love
him just I just wish literally only
that's right I hope that like this
debuts that like number one on [ __ ]
billboard yeah oh whatever that means
like that's like I feel like psycho
Taylor Swift I was like I know but one
on on the chart of charts okay I okay
billboard is the chart of charts but to
me the only chart that matters is iTunes
I know but I know what it actually
matter your music except that it doesn't
even matter
nothing because it doesn't count for
streaming right so it actually doesn't
matter literally at all I know but to me
it just I exert that I can I check
iTunes literally on the daily just cuz I
like to know like what people are
listening to and that's just what I
gauge is also wasn't supposed to go away
like a long time ago yeah I hope that it
never does um except that I tried to buy
the album on my phone and I couldn't
figure it out because it's just Apple
music like I could just play it I
couldn't buy it I'm sure were you in the
iTunes Store yes I was in the iTunes
Store purchased and they also had to
send on my computer I had it pre-ordered
um
I I'll figure out how to do it but like
I hope iTunes never goes away there's
nothing like paying one dollar and
twenty-nine cents for a song that you
believe in you know like toast by
Claudia so literally I always feel like
I'm really supporting the artists once I
buy their music yeah you're such you're
such a supportive times I like me to be
your like your fan artists can only
dream of having a fan like snitch yeah
like I literally people think that like
I work for Lou Combs yeah like they
don't realize this it's pro bono like
he's literally never recognized she's
volunteered well no you get recognition
I get recognition from everyone but Luke
and you know what that is enough for me
he's busy he's busy you know I don't
care yeah I don't care
he's busy making banger I don't want to
sound ungrateful I'm not well without
further ado I think it is time for the
fat side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast but before we do
that I must let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by legacy box
I'm really glad that legacy box is one
of today's sponsors because it is so
pertinent to our Seanie situation and
it's one of those companies where it's
like the idea once you hear it it's like
oh how did I not think of that right
eclis they send you an empty box which
is great you don't have to like go
looking for a box to fit all of your
things that you do it's like so key and
you send them like old VCRs film
anything that you want like old memories
to be converted digitally and then they
will send it back to you in a way that
you can watch it or view these photos
digitally so you have them truly forever
so we started working with legacy box a
while ago I sent them some of our old we
have so many home movies cuz we were
like such hams
I mean we make home movies here every
day so like imagine what we had we were
young
right so we got these tapes back of us
singing the Spice Girls and it's just
like none of us have changed mmm you
know snitches steal snitch a Claudia is
still like with her voice I'm trying to
be in the center yeah and I'm still like
taking it way too seriously
yeah I like dancing yeah it's like being
so [ __ ] extra yeah but it's just like
so nice to take a trip down memory lane
and with legacy box you are able to do
that
legacy box is simply the best way to
convert all your old analog media to DVD
thumb drive or even convenient digital
download so you can easily share with
other members of your family it's an
amazing gift especially around the
holidays like give the gift of memories
you have the gift of memories you mean
like what I'm Kim did for Kris but just
in a way that we can afford right this
is like the Kim gift in a way that you
can afford plus the process from start
to finish is so easy you go online and
push it purchase the box that you need
they send you a legacy box kit and you
fill them with all of your media you
slap on a prepaid mailing label and send
it back over 700,000 families have
trucked have trusted legacy box legacy
box has been in business over a decade
and is the interesting industry leader
in professionally digitizing family
memories if memory is the diary you
carry legacy box be the fresh ink that's
really beautiful
wow that is beautiful get started
preserving your past today go to see box
comm slash toast to get 40% off your
first offer save your time and memories
go to legacy box comm slash toast and
save 40% on your first order okay you
guys this is an amazing thing to do
especially as a gift if you're thinking
yeah Daichi is like right in time for
Thanksgiving
like share these memories with your
family it's really it really is sign-on
take a trip down memory lane oh ho dem
Assyria wait okay I just need a sip of
coffee before we get by the way
apparently you set up VCRs and it's VHS
but you know what I honestly thought
they were the same but HS that you put
in your VCR know what I meant you knows
no you know you know okay first story PC
A's recap because I watch the whole
damned the fakest
award show that exists basically sanic
even watch who didn't watch it and
coming from someone who did watch it
there were definitely like fake things
happening where you know the person who
the ward is the person who showed up the
only people who showed up were winners
but maybe because they knew they were
gonna like the only people who showed up
were winners I'm sorry you were
stressing so heavily that it was fan
voted that like if it's not true to the
fan votes I think people would be riding
in the streets I don't know I don't
honestly don't think people care enough
about the PCs to be riding and I don't
know it was actually really fun award
toy it felt like what a word should be
first of all award shows should be fan
voted because like I don't really care
about like the film Academy and to like
no one was taking it too seriously
the the show was two hours flat it
literally just ended like someone who
was presenting award was like bye guys
have a great night and it like didn't
drag on like they always do and I just
said there were only two performances
which I realized like no one really
needs these performances and award shows
I live for the performances it's the
best part um
Alessia Cara and Kelsea Ballerini
performs like interesting choices here
for it and the kardashians show up to
the PCAs which is they have to probably
underground directing but like we get
Cardassians like on a red carpet
talking to juliana like answering
questions and honestly the dynamic
between the sisters was on one last
night wait why like they just courtney
and like was being weird and like kim
cut her off and i think it was also in
the way they were standing it's like you
probably couldn't hear where the other
was so they like someone would start
talking and then someone else would like
cut them off because you probably
couldn't hear that someone had started
talking it was just a little weird yeah
it was definitely something there's
definitely something something there
there's suddenly something something
there and that is our actually our next
story so we'll get to it but some of the
winners people's champion award pink was
like a winner that wasn't nominated
right it was like her speech was I think
the best speech of the night and second
place Beach was Cole Sprouse who
literally made me laugh so our wait what
do you say he's funny he was so funny he
was nominated against like Brad Pitt
Julio for her and he was like you guys
like Bradley oh there's always next year
it was actually really funny and then
Noah sent in a oh one after him and it
was the most Awkward speech I ever heard
in my whole [ __ ] life it's like I was
cringing from home Noah walked so Kokoro
know what could barely walk because
apparently he he busted his leg where
was Alexis Wren why wouldn't they walk
together I don't know fashion icon
Gwen Stefani she was being really cute
her and Blake were so cute they both I
love ditches and they were being so
cutie she really just didn't care what
like people thought about her in her
speech I Chris peach kind of made no
sense I'm sure I wouldn't know to say
either she like was just fine about it
it was it was really funny um and then
Jennifer Aniston won people's icon of
2019 and you know she's not my cup of
tea but I thought her speech was great
and she was actually like really happy
to be there she probably was like didn't
want to show up but she has to promote
the morning show and they promised her
this big award so she was like okay I'll
go write but they played this highlight
reel or for a whole career and I think
she was really moved Adam Sandler me the
speech about her and I think she was
really glad she went okay yeah I mean
honestly like she's been growing on me I
can't lie like I used to be like maybe
it's because I watch friends now and so
I could but Claudius doesn't even like
her but honestly like I have nothing
against her no me neither she's growing
on me more and more and like I'm
starting to ship her and Brad again Oh
big-time big-time like Angelina I
shipped my name was time I should work
out I'll just [ __ ] like I'll ship
anything I know but I shipped Angelina
and Brad at the time but I'm starting to
feel like I was on the wrong side of
history I don't know I really don't know
I feel like I was just like so young at
the time I'll explain it on my naivete
totally okay the movie of 2019 was
Avengers endgame comedy movie of 2019
was murder mystery but that's because
Adam Sandler and Jennifer Aniston were
there and it's like they don't show up
to lose faith or Joe in that instance
definitely a fake award show action
movie of 2019 Avengers end game drama
movie after okay okay I gotta talk about
that wait right before they won it one
drama movie and it wasn't like announced
on TV they just smiled I saw an ad for
it on my phone and I want to watch it
absolutely watch it I read every single
book the books were amazing it's based
off of Harry Styles fan fiction which is
just like weird and of itself but
whatever and I was so excited for the
film it was a major motion picture like
it was in theatres it's like it's on
Netflix now so everyone's watching and
thinking it's a Netflix original like I
literally every day I wake up to text me
like you have to watch after and I'm
like no I know like I read the books but
people think it's just enough Netflix
original of like a good bad movie but
like no like there was time invested
into this movie and it's like supposed
to be like the next like Twilight
sort of thing except like not
supernatural and it's just the way that
they did this first movie was so [ __ ]
terrible like you don't even understand
so it's not good it's good bad it's like
I I've never created I it took me three
hours to get through this movie because
I kept pausing so I was squirming with
cringing like I couldn't even handle it
but I had to finish it yeah but and it's
like they knew that it was bad because
they have literally recasted everyone in
them in the film they got a new director
the new directors a person who did cruel
intentions for the sequel and it's and
now like dealing Sprouse is in the
second one and I think they're like
revamping it cuz like they know that
they [ __ ] botch it but I'm not
surprised that they won because the
after fans like yeah stand to its core
you know okay I just couldn't believe
that it was awarded something because it
was literally like the cringy I have
ever watched and I'm a fan because I
read I literally read the books yeah the
girl who the star looks like I thought
while I was watching the trailer I
thought it was Chloe grace Moretz but
then another time she looks like Lee
Reinhard and she literally looks like a
combination of the two of them she looks
like her sister Catherine Langford okay
and then I googled her and I saw her
last name was Langford and I meant to
click to see if she had a sister but I
guess it kind of Baker did I guess I got
distracted
Hanna Baker 13 reasons why that I don't
watch society she's not in society oh
what's the girlfriend Society Christine
broseph no Oh Kathryn Newton Kathir it
was another Kathryn okay okay I'm not
totally out of touch family movie of
2019 Aladdin male movie star of 2019
Robert Downey jr. female movie star 2019
zendaya who looked incredible on her
hair she just like was so beautiful her
dress she's just such an icon and she's
so gracious and every speech that she
makes it's like so well said she's so
well-spoken she's spoken she's like just
such a great role model for this next
generation um and I love her so much
that I might give you for you like a
real chance I think you should I'd be
interested to hear thoughts just because
like I didn't get it oh you didn't I did
not under I watch the whole thing I just
didn't understand it but people are
gonna come bring it I mean I said that
last time everyone was like you don't
have enough depth to understand okay
wait if you didn't get it then I
probably like you should watch it also
because it's really part of the culture
now so like yeah for your job
okay drama movie star Cole Sprouse five
feet apart comedy movie star Noah
Centennial action movie star Tom Holland
most of these awards weren't announced
on TV I feel like the ones where like
like a animated movie star Beyonce won
so they didn't announce it on TV because
Beyonce's not they Taylor Swift won like
Album of 2019 she wasn't there right so
that's what so maybe the ones that they
announce on TV were the ones of people
that came and that's how it was
unwritten tonne rig that's still rigged
because it's what we're seeing no but
like they still won they get their
little thing in the mail and as the
award that's most pertinent to us
podcast pop podcast of 2019 went to
Tania and Becca again and I'm really
very sorry I'm very happy for them and
I'm happy for Becca because now she gets
one trophy and Tania gets another it's
fair and I just podcast it with Tania on
Thursday night for Friday's episode and
she is just such a precious gem of a
woman and I couldn't be happier
no she's like literally so nice she's so
easiest thing ever that's what I hope to
be that nice one day I know you could
learn a lot for I could learn so much
and her niceness has been rewarded with
a second PCA PCA
love it I could really watch me from 6
o'clock to 11:30 last night I watched
the whole red carpet because I thought
that like Tania and Justin we're gonna
be on the TV show but turns out they
were just on the Twitter stream she's
just like so not in tune it's time for
them to retire giuliana rancic yeah she
did alright and then I watched the show
and then I watched Knightley pop they
did the nightly pop Awards Sean Paul
Jones showed up he was being really
funny he is funny yeah he was like it's
really just an honor to be nominated for
an NP a it was really funny
so that was my night oh and then I
watched Shark Tank where the ageism is
out of control like for which yes I'm
usually the old people on the show oh
that's so neat I'm a kid comes in with
the worst idea ever they like of course
make a deal but like an old person they
not only don't make a deal but like they
make fun of them and they just like
berate them and yeah the peanut butter
pump wasn't the best idea but honestly
like I've I I'd get it there's so many
like dumb tools that are just sold in
like the kitchen section that like how
people know I literally spent my entire
day yesterday catching up on
in Riverdale and then also do you watch
all American no I think you but you
would enjoy it but I have a lot of stuff
to watch now but I started looking for
Alaska remember I told you that I think
it's a show we should all watch yeah so
I started it I'm on Episode six out of
eight and it's actually a really good
Joseph is like literally the actress of
our generation Wow
she is just like such a good actress and
I feel like she's gonna go so far the
show like moves a little bit slow but
it's just kind of enjoyable to watch but
I think that you would enjoy it and yeah
that's what I did okay I'm gonna watch
it also grain downs me like just made an
amazing point
I can't hear PCI without thinking about
Zoey 101 I can totally I knew it sounded
okay when I was saying and I was like
this is not what it's meant to mean okay
I will check out Looking for Alaska
there are so many new Christmas movies
on Netflix that I got it's know I got a
watch everyone's talking I got a watch
I'm kind of a kind of want to save it
though I don't know I don't want to just
like watch it on a Tuesday yeah but I
feel like I have a lot of flights coming
up and I'll cut like and the crown is
coming back soon oh my god I'm honestly
like not mentally prepared to watch the
crown what do you mean it's just like
it's just like really like slow and like
dense interesting I'm so gonna watch it
I know it's so good to be interesting
cause it also they're jumping they're
jumping ahead so it's like a new
character and I think towards the end of
the season we get Princess Diana so like
that would be an interesting that will
be interesting because they never really
watched like any documentary about
Princess Diana so I'm excited to get it
from the crown yeah and the crowd like I
feel like everyone's divided on the way
that we remember Princess Diana and I'm
interested to see which side the crown
takes because I think the crown is
generally favorable toward the palace
right right right so it'll be
interesting it'll be interesting it on
this show
okay next story Kourtney Kardashian says
she'll be taking a step back from
Keeping Up with the Kardashians by okay
this is really crazy Courtney well all
the sisters were on Entertainment
Tonight with Kelty and she was to be the
Kelty Kelty I'm so happy she was just
asking like the most pertinent question
she asked about rise and shine we talked
about that on Friday and she talks about
Kourtney taking a step back Kourtney
said quote I just decided to spend more
time as a mom and put more of my energy
there she explained but I'm not saying
goodbye I think you'll have to see more
of it
the new season season 18 it isn't airing
yet but it's being filmed currently in
this room I guess they had cameras with
them so what this is that means Dallas
he's gonna be on Keeping Up oh my god I
hope so
I feel as though we can see how this
would happen like I feel like the
sisters are just fighting a lot in
Courtney's like place on Keeping Up it's
just always being the complainer like
that she doesn't want to be there yeah
she doesn't like it like I feel as
though they don't even like filming with
her and she just maybe needs to take a
step back in order to appreciate it
right and I think this will be
ultimately a good thing however I feel
like were unique and the toasters in
taking kitten side
oh man wouldn't what kid she was I feel
like everyone really took Courtney side
on that um I feel like the fans I don't
hate Courtney as much as we do that's
possibly maybe like people are actually
Davis Tata about it maybe I mean should
still be around but it's like she was a
key player yeah
but I think she'll just like become more
like Kendall and Kylie where it's like
some episode she's in some time but show
that she's not I'm so fine with it like
I'm so sick of hearing her complain and
like honestly like I think she needs us
like every time she like got on screen
she was crying cuz like I don't know
like I think she needs some time yeah
Somerby says Courtney is the first mom
to ever exist no it's the craziest thing
like look at where your sisters have
accomplished and their mothers like I
don't want to [ __ ] hear it ya know
I'm and also her kids are the oldest so
they really require the least amount of
work because they go to school like she
has the day until 3 o'clock like she and
film until 3:00 and then pick her kids
up like her making an excuse at like she
can't film as much because she wants to
focus on being a mom like that doesn't
really like hold water because Kim has
more kids than her and does more than
her but I feel like that's not
necessarily why she's not feeling but
now she's gonna use all that extra time
to focus even more right I'm being a mom
also because kid people I'm saying that
our kids are like out of control lately
so like maybe like she also really does
need to take some time and be a mom and
like get a spanking yeah just getting
like do I'm not gonna tell it mom what
to do yeah yeah but but do you think
that Kourtney is doing this in a way to
be like because so many times in the
show like Chloe's been like okay so just
leave like if you're gonna keep them
clean like just go do you think this is
her way
I'm gonna leave it like watch the show
tank where I was like that's not gonna
that's not gonna happen I think it's
just like she's she's tired and she's
fed up and she like I think you need to
just take a step back from something in
order to ever come back to it if you
love something set it free and if it was
ever truly yours it will return okay so
I think I think that's where we're at
but she's always been like a mainstay on
the show it's been her full-time job
yeah like her paycheck is gonna go down
I technically should I think they split
the I think it's a hundred million
dollars thing I was 150 for all the
seasons and I think they split that
equally except for I don't think Kylie
takes any of it um this is just my like
picture hynnyín yeah uh and I think
she'll still get paid because I don't
think it's about the money for any like
hmm you know look she's not doing
anything no but she'll just be on it
less okay okay think maybe like can I
think Kendall gets paid from the show I
honestly I don't know but Scott like
gets paid get Scott's on it so much he
should be getting it he's definitely
getting paid yeah yeah like he's putting
Sophia Ritchie on it he's definitely
getting paid do you see the sisters and
Chris and Cory at the awards last night
yeah they just looked so did you know
before he Gamble's 39 I found that out
today cuz the toasters were saying he's
younger than not even IDs everything
corny like he's in his 30s it's yeah
it's it's it's mind-blowing like I saw
all of their posts like 39 and all the
jerseys and I was like was he born in
1939 I was like white I was like is he
39 and then I looked it up and he was 39
I was like holy [ __ ] that's he's the
exact same a just Kim that's crazy it's
crazy like him and Chris really work you
know no 100% and I love that actually
but I was just genuinely never thought
about how old you may be I've never than
39 yeah well maybe you associate him as
older I don't know I wonder if you had
asked me before I knew why would I you
would not have said 39 that's for damn
sure
maybe not maybe I would have said 40 I
would have said like a nice 45
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay uh next up
Teresa Giudice and her daughter is leave
Italy after visiting Joe Giudice quote
love you see you soon okay
the Giudice women are in Italy visiting
Joe and
and Real Housewives of New Jersey
cameras followed them there and they
just had to leave they posted some
really cute instagrams over the weekend
obviously Joe was on his tippy toes
that's what everyone's talking I saw I
mean these girls are just getting so big
like what is he supposed to do it when
he's just getting smaller and smaller
smaller and smaller smaller and smaller
smaller really sad I haven't watched New
Jersey premiere yet because I have not
had the time and I'm gonna watch you
tonight so we can talk about it tomorrow
because like you don't even watch no but
the season looks so freakin good is that
Italy stuffs gonna be in this season yes
I believe so
Wow actually they might jump to because
usually they don't feel they don't feel
anything like while it's airing right
but this was necessary this was
necessary just like on Beverly Hills
when they had the lunch app like without
Lisa Vanderpump was filmed like much
later than everything else oh right
right
I can't believe Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills and Atlanta were nominated
for pcs last night interesting yeah they
really got a lot of the nominations they
did them really well like the under
prime paroles Keeping Up with the
Kardashians they also had reality TV
competitor Hannah brown one did you see
her court I didn't see the whole speech
because it got cut off in the Instagram
video that I was watching I just more so
saw one more so on to see like the vibe
between like her fellow competitors and
like when she won hug Colton I think her
and Colton are fine and I'm like Tyler
see I just like couldn't like honestly
like I just felt I just hoped so
uncomfortable for her and then did you
see that everyone that was like at that
was Bachelorette PCs like they all went
out last night but like she just went
home but she was also she's done dancing
with the stars in it okay that's why she
but it's just like in the whole thing
must be so weird it's like did they
really have to seat them at the same
[ __ ] table like it's just like hilar
see thing is we that's what I'm saying
I've seen people there so her
ex-boyfriend right but they are fine he
went to he goes to Dancing with the
Stars
yeah but they are fine yeah it was it
was definitely weird she looked amazing
though she did she looked amazing yeah
you were you were happy for her as her
number one Stan yeah why even think she
actually you think um no she's beautiful
and she's like her body is getting like
crazy body is getting from teen stars
she's not my kind of dress but like she
was really cute and roll type was funny
did she say real time she didn't of
course he did
so back to Joe and Teresa everyone's
letting me know this is for a separate
special that they're filming love
turning out that extra content yeah um
this is just like really sad and really
crazy and I don't know I can't believe
like honestly the most shocking thing to
me is like how big all the girls are
like Milania is they I always just think
of her as like a little Milania yeah
but she's all grown and Gabriella what's
so crazy is like Teresa had Gabrielle
Gabrielle Audrina Audrina she had her on
the show that's freaky that no she's a
bad day she was a bad bet on the show in
like the size of Audriana is how long
we've had Real Housewives of New Jersey
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy times I mean I
came with Gia's go to college I know I'm
really excited to see gia and Frankie
are they go to the same school no but
they went to prom together oh it's on
the show the show are they dating I
don't think so I feel like it was a
friend day yeah it was like maybe her
boyfriend backed out and her mom was
like I'll get you a date sweetie
see how it went down anyways I'll be
watching New Jersey tonight we'll be
recapping it tomorrow so I need to tell
Claudia to watch okay
I'm excited for our next story yeah what
is it well before I can tell you what it
is I need to let you know that today's
episode is also you brought to you by a
toast favorite daily harvest because we
are all overbooked overstimulated and
constantly running on empty for me I'm
always rushing to do podcasts and then I
barely have enough time to do anything
else let alone eat like a hardy freaky
meal which is why I love daily harvest
because it makes it so easy for me to
eat like real food but on the go daily
harvest makes it easy to eat more fruits
and vegetables with thoroughly sourced
shift crafted foods that can be prepared
in five minutes or less each recipe
takes one step to prepare with room to
make them your own
add your favorite Mills to bun to
smoothie or beat up a harvest or heat up
a harvest bowl and top it with avocado
or fried egg oh my god that sounds
delicious
honestly I have a few daily harvests in
my freezer and when the show is over I'm
going to chow down whoo maybe avocado
love me some avocado also this is
perfect for my CMA Awards diet daily
harvest sports directly with farmers to
harvest organic fruits and vegetables at
their peak and freezes them within 24
hours to lock in the nutrients
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to enjoy it if you
want to enjoy daily harvest as
well go to daily harvest command enter
promo code toast to get $25 off your
first box that's promo code toast for
$25 off your first box at daily harvest
com daily harvest com promo code toast
like start eating healthy Earth's
perfect for Millennials like us on the
go like whoever really has time to eat
breakfast but with daily hardly remember
you don't have to sacrifice like
nutrition and just eating well no I'm
with you I wish I had time but I don't
it was harvest you'll you'll have the
time I'll have a time okay next story is
what everyone is talking about this week
Instagram is about to star be having
light counts in the u.s. it's like the
second I actually start getting likes I
go away well we've been talking about
this for a while and it was rolling out
elsewhere but it hadn't come here and
now this week Adam CEO Adam oh sorry
announced at a Wired event in San
Francisco on Friday but this week it is
coming to America I'm like fine with it
I just feel like now like my feeds gonna
get like a lot chiller you know yeah I'm
like I'm excited to see what people are
actually doing with their lives and what
they actually look like so that'll be
exciting it's just like literally the
second I started getting likes has
happened it's just like weird but
whatever well the like still matter
because if you are an influencer and
you're working with brands like you'll
still need to like prove do you still
get to see you get to see but no one
else gets to see ok and I think it's
exciting I mean I think it's important
for just like mental health because like
for sure that's like measuring ourselves
in likes is just not a way to live but I
think it's actually gonna be great for
creativity like I feel like so many
times people don't people don't post
pictures that they might post because
they think it's not gonna do well right
but now you're just gonna post the
pictures that you want to post isn't
you're gonna start posting garbage
content but it takes away that anxiety
of like what do people are people gonna
respond to this photo that's Amer I feel
like for me like now you can really just
focus on your photo creating content and
yeah and your flow like I posted a
mirror picture yesterday and I was like
I'm excited for her I'm like so go away
cuz it's gonna meet on their pics all
the time which not gonna be all mirror
pics all the time but like sometimes
mirror pics are kind of boring they
don't do so well but I either want to
show off my outfit or it's just like the
next thing that like I need in my flow
because well it's the only photo that
you got right it's or it's the only
that you [ __ ] gotta feel like
it's gonna take a lot of emphasis off of
people like going and doing photo shoots
like so these crazy lengths yeah where
it's like a nice photo like just post
the photo that you have yeah I don't
like sometimes you can go out of the way
do a photo shoot
bah-bah-bah but you don't have to like
break your like your back to get the
shot ya know I'm with you and so I feel
like it'll be like it's just it's times
are changing you know times are changing
and you just gotta adjust the times I
think this is a really responsible move
on instagrams part obviously I'll be
upset that I can no longer like really
see who has fake followers but they're
like [ __ ] engagement um everything
you could to kind of see based off
comments maybe comments maybe maybe I
don't know people still do that thing
where they like reply to every comment
so if you got like oh my god but then
but then when you see that you know that
this person's a fraud yeah like when I
see people replying to every single
comment even if someone replies like a
heart no even if someone comment too
hard and then they reply like a hard
it's like why is that necessary I don't
know I don't know well it's necessary
because they're like worried about their
engagement so I guess that will be a
good telltale sign but if like for all
these like fake bloggers out there I
feel like this is the best thing that
could happen to them you know because
yeah because they don't have to worry
about likes anymore
yeah or for people who's like whose
contents gotten really stale maybe they
have like all real followers but like
the followers just like don't like their
photos so they don't come to the top of
the algorithm and anyone who like blames
the algorithm for their engagement like
they're so excited we got the worst is
what I see bloggers like post like have
you guys that like might know they're
like my photos like not showing up in
your Isis feed to hear like I'm just
gonna like link it here like this is my
new post and it's just like that I saw
it and I just didn't like it it sounds
like Instagram is working perfectly well
yeah it's a machine like it's working
it's time it's working for everyone else
like it's fine I can't I can yeah but I
think it's gonna I think this is like a
huge change you know it's like one small
step for man one huge step for mankind I
think this is really gonna like change
social media or maybe it won't at all I
don't know um I don't know I don't know
about like long-term effects like I
don't know what it could actually do
besides just make people like help
people feel better and stop comparing
themselves to others that would be like
a great that would be a great thing
but then aside from that I don't know if
it's gonna change social media as we
know it I don't think it will make
people stop comparing themselves to
others because still people will have
like Instagram FOMO and just like
posting you know doing it for the gram
and doing it for the toast obviously um
but I think it's like gonna change the
way people feel just about themselves
compared to themselves like you just
maybe post a picture you don't get that
many likes you're like oh I look like
[ __ ] yeah you'll lose that yeah we're
like that's fair I guess people will
still let you know what they think of
you in the comments yeah like if I'm not
going out I'm not getting a lot of
comments the photo student if they don't
like your jacket
the like no and the cop oh my god I
can't be having spoken about it but your
jacket took the world by storm this week
it took the world by storm this weekend
I just got this jacket last week I
literally saw it I was like oh my god I
have to have it I found it online and I
like needed to use honey in order to get
and I'm so obsessed with this code it's
like this
cleany tie-dyed vibe sack spot coat and
like my picture did really well so many
people loved it but like so many people
thought it was like the ugliest track it
ever they were using the word hideous
and when someone says this is hit does
that mean that's short for hideous would
you check urban dictionary
I remember I've never heard it and maybe
like this is a hit like maybe maybe it's
like I never thought for one second that
this jacket we just like take the world
by storm
nobody would be so mad about it like
it's literally just like a colorful
puffer no I'd never thought it would be
so controversial
so why like I just don't like threads
about it like it was just like whoa like
it's the weekend go go party like go do
something it was so crazy and people
were saying like I looked like a big
marshmallow as if that was a bad thing
that's like kind of the point of a
puffer made like a side-by-side of like
me in like a plea knee marshmallow and I
was like you don't have sent to me like
that government that's goals like I
don't know it was crazy it was crazy
like I can't whatever these people are
talking about you know totally and I
freaking love the jacket it's littering
me and a jacket it does mean it yes it
doesn't mean hideous okay or like this
hits that's so [ __ ] funny I love that
[ __ ] hit okay good to know you learn
something new every day
yeah I'm learning something new
every day good stuff yeah okay ready for
our next story oh wait is about your
jacket
yeah video problems spotted China hid
jacket jacket Oh problems that'll be my
next caption guys look out for it and
make sure like it but even if you don't
it's okay because instagrams hiding
likes are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am it's a little bit of
business before I can get into it I must
let you know that the biz news is
brought to you by liquid IV for all my
tipsy toasters out there and toasters
who are interested in staying hydrated
liquid IV is the fastest most efficient
way to get hydrated it actually is it
actually is I'm on liquid IV heavy diet
regimen this week because I need to get
hydrated before CMAs because my skin is
just like garbage I accidentally got
your package of liquid IV and I never
gave it back to you because I stole it
because it's that good trying to drink
more water liquid IV hydrates you two to
three times faster and more efficiently
than water alone with the added bonus of
vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and b12 feel good and
do good liquid IV has donated 1.5
million sticks to date to places like
Haiti Uganda Puerto Rico and most
recently Nepal with each purchase you
make liquid IV donates a serving to
someone in need around the world liquid
IV helps prevent jetlag and headaches
when traveling ts a friendly and is
perfect for on-the-go travelers helps to
keep your skin hydrated while flying and
can be used before during and after
flights okay this is literally meant for
me when I sigh I just become like a
shriveled up raisin and I need liquid I
be desperately also I've been having
like a headache for the past 48 hours in
your eyebrow like yeah right in my like
that's so weird Nicole had an eyebrow
headache and she like kept saying all
that Evan eyebrow headache I don't know
what I think it's just like a migraine
but I do need that I do know that I need
to become more hydrated and I need to
just cut the chase cut to the chase and
use liquid IV liquid IV is the
fastest-growing wellness brand you can
find them everywhere even Costco you can
find their hydration multipliers sold at
all Costco's nationwide it's a healthy
alternative to traditional sugary sports
drinks no artificial flavors
preservatives like some of the other
hydration quote unquote hydrating
hydrators it contains five essential
vitamins including more vitamin C than
an orange and is
potassium as a banana okay you have I
love potassium you got to get yourself
some liquid IV I love liquid IV and I
know you will too right now our
listeners get 25% off at liquid I be
calm when you use our code toast at
checkout that's 25% off anything you
order on liquid IDs website go to liquid
IV calm and enter our promo code toes to
get your savings and start getting
better hydration that's liquid IV
dot-com promo code toast
don't wait start properly hydrating
today also like when I run out of those
still and package I'll renew Oh totally
tis the season for hydrating also just
his a season y'all like I can't stop
getting excited for the holidays it's so
exciting
are you feeling that Christmas cheer I'm
feeling that Christmas cheer I'm just
like loving winter this season I usually
like I always dread it in that was like
I'm like dad I love summer so that cup
so yeah and like now I'm just like
living for winter and I brought all of
my winter clothes to my apartment and so
like things are just like really just
taking a turn like that sweater
yeah but I'm leading a life of regret so
I can't stop looking at my phone cuz
it's like you can't wear stripes on
camera and I don't even think about it
I'm I'm looking very large but you look
very cute in person thank you but I
understand I'm sorry I didn't even think
of it that's how you're gonna go out
everyone was loving my sweater earlier
and it's I've literally had this sweater
dress since high school yeah I have it
in black if I stole it from you it's
theory and I'm realizing everything
theory that I've ever owned I've had for
10 years me too and I that's just that
theory every good sweater like every
everything that's never lost anything
theory this pleated skirt that I wear at
least once a week on the show is
literally mine from high school like the
zippers broken I don't even care yeah I
have so many things like that
yeah like will just never be they'll
never go away they'll never go away okay
good then final story a little bit news
a little discriminatory news because
this is [ __ ] up Apple co-founder says
Goldman's Apple card algorithm
discriminates Apple Inc and Goldman
Sachs Group Inc two of the most
recognizable companies in tech and
finance are caught up in a growing
debate over whether lenders
unintentionally discriminate when they
use complex models to determine how
Americans borrow money on Saturday
bloomberg reported that a Wall Street
regulator had opened a probe into
Goldman's credit card product
is after a viral tweet from a tech
entrepreneur alleged that the Apple
carts algorithms discriminated against
his wife now another high-profile user
of the Apple card Apple co-founder Steve
Wozniak is calling for the government to
get involved citing excessive corporate
reliance on mysterious technology quote
these sorts of unfairness bother me and
go against the principle of truth we
don't have transparency and how these
companies set these things up and
operate Wozniak said he can borrow ten
times as much as his wife on their Apple
cards even though they share bank and
other credit card accounts and that
other lenders treat them equally so
people are saying now that like women
are getting less like what's the word
credit limit credit limit then men like
that these algorithms are biased against
women interesting I was not
understanding one word that you were
saying and that's why I just summed it
up for you in layman's terms in layman's
terms that's [ __ ] up and not cool yeah
I want like what it why why what what's
the point in that so you know you're
gonna get called out maybe they think
women are irresponsible no but they get
to like just say it's like this
hocus-pocus algorithm but you don't know
what the outer isms doing that they made
it yeah I coded it algorithms thing I
think women are very financially
response they're very fiscally
responsible
I'm as a woman I'm very fiscally
responsible sure you know I am like if
you give me a credit limit like that's
the freaking limit
well yeah cuz you fill sure I think just
men like crazy go buy cars nice to be
trusted I saw hustlers and they just
like go charge up all these yeah credits
that's cuz their credits was so high
that's true and rise um I just thought
this was a crazy story and like Steve
Wozniak is getting involved like against
Apple makes you think this Apple card it
looks I actually saw a commercial for it
that looks really enticing but like why
would I switch my card to an Apple card
you know what I mean it's like I'm it's
like maybe if I didn't have one I would
be like oh maybe the Apple card but like
I also don't want to be someone who's
getting to be one of the first people to
have an Apple card like at least like
with like chase or things like that like
you know it's good and you know it works
like this is you don't know
yeah but yes they have it's Apple and
Goldman Sachs so like you you trust yeah
I guess but they
you trust and then you're [ __ ] that's
what happens yeah but I think someone
was saying in this article that this is
an issue that happens with a lot of like
banks and their algorithms and that
they're just like inherently biased
against women and I just think it's
[ __ ] up like let the women spend man
that's [ __ ] up
you know fix it anyways that was our
fifth and final story the snatchler oh
my god I just don't want this show to
end because this is like the last show
I'm gonna do with you in a while because
um you're you're leaving I'm leaving and
I'm so excited for you and it's just
like the definition of bittersweet
it really is it's so wild it's so bitter
but it's so sweet it's so bitter it's so
sweet I'm growing up you are and it's
wild and this was always a plan it just
took like a little longer than expected
ya know honestly it came to quickly
honestly yeah well it's great because
you have brought back the snatchler
which is just my favorite podcast and we
will get to go on this journey with you
so yeah like you won't be sitting on
this in each and every day like telling
you like I'm not disappearing guys yeah
we're gonna hear from you once a week
like you're going to share your life
updates as you like figure out this
world I know I'm so it's like I feel
like I'm just like I don't know what a
good analogy is but it's like when you
like blossom know like spread your wings
and fly yeah and it's like what if I
crash and burn what if I don't know
you're like a little cocooned worm who's
about to turn into a butterfly I hope I
turn into a butterfly what if I die you
won't you're already a butterfly biggest
most beautiful butterfly in the world no
I know it's so crazy but like also I
think I'm gonna be here tomorrow so oh
you will be here tomorrow um and but
you'll be back on the same day like I'm
Friday oh wow I like don't get like one
day yeah well you're not coming to
Nashville this week
that's so excited and nervous for
Nashville I just
I'm freaking I just like I said don't
envy you but I'm excited for you I'm
excited to watch your journey it's gonna
be crazy it's gonna be crazy
no you're gonna the best time ever and
it's just like no we always do but you
know these things like it's it's it's an
honor it's an honor and they just I
don't take it lightly it's not learn it
spit it's an honor it's a pleasure and
it's a pit for sure for sure and the
stress like it's just gonna
you're hyping stress up so much now
because of the way it looks but it's
like this dress is gonna be the death of
me oh yeah 100% super sad like it's
[ __ ] tiny honestly it really is it's
like hanging in my apartment and it
literally it looks like it's like for a
doll
oh man well what else do we need to
recap I caught up on Real Housewives of
Dallas are you going up on dynasty yes
you want I need to talk about it because
as the number one I think we're like the
number one dynasty podcast fans like I
don't know I don't know one other
podcast that talks about diamonds right
except like they went on this accent
show but he made it very clear that he
never watched an episode so as like the
number one fans of dynasty I just want
to say like I'm not loving this season
me neither Adam is ruining it for me
there are so many like new storylines
that are taking away from like our
precious gem of a Fallon yeah and
obviously I'm so tired of like Fallon is
falling into like this Blair Waldorf
syndrome where like she schemes every
episode and then at the end like feels
terrible and falls on her ass you know
such a good comparison and it's like
every episode you think she's learned
but then she wakes up in the manor and
it's a new day and she has a new scheme
yeah but I like the schemes I don't mind
the schemes but I want you to feel good
about them right I only like the schemes
like if they pan out like scheme for
Lemon and win him back yeah yeah but
then ya know I'm with you and like I'm
not really liking this season either and
I it genuinely pains me to say it but
it's like I'd like to see the foul and
that's like out there and killing it not
like literally everyone basically
dancing on her grades like even Kirby is
like writing and sounds not like that
that doesn't fly with me and it's just
like we've gone through so many like
Liam and falen trials and tribulations
and we were finally there it's like he
doesn't [ __ ] remember her now I know
oh and then oh maybe now he actually
does at the end of this episode and it's
like but she's with Trixie's brother and
it's like of course what he's gonna show
about her door now in the next episode
not in the next episode but like in the
next few episodes obviously like his
memories gonna come back to him and I
just can't wait till he realizes that
Adams the one who hit him over the head
and I think oh I forgot that might be
the end of Adam once we am finally
remember I'm praying that Adam is blind
except that Adam is regular or regular
he's in the he's in the whatever it's
just not gonna work for me unless
they just like if I can go from like
hating Kelly Dodd to like her being my
favorite housewife like Adam can turn it
around too especially when it's like
writers writing it right so if you want
to keep him on the show that's fine but
like he needs to come around and he
needs to stop like trying to take down
the family and the whole thing really
makes no sense like why is he so out to
get Fallon like even so much so does to
send her to jail he's obsessed with
Blake and just wants to be Blake's
number one it's just all so when like
Blake should have sent him packing when
he sent the divers into the lake oh all
right big-time big-time big-time also
something is like you're being stupid
like seems stupid something that's
ruining the season for me is crystal 3.0
not anything wrong with her and maybe if
she had been the original crystal like I
wouldn't think anything but I was loving
crystal two point I was loving crystal
taken out and that meant even so much
because I loved crystal one point out
it's like for me to come around to
Crystal 2.0 like I just loved Anna
Brendan and like and she was a like
crystal 2.0 is a badass and like she
just had that energy and crystal 3.0 it
just just doesn't have it she's not
giving me badass energy no and it's
making it really she's not giving me BAE
it's making it but this is what I don't
understand we know for a fact that the
writers of this show have absolutely no
problem writing people out of shows like
literally left right and center people
are just gotten Stephen who gone he's a
brother gone and I think every everyone
Under the Sun hates Adam right but no
they're they decide to know [ __ ] you not
liking Adam we're gonna make him a
regular yeah not chill well there always
needs to be a villian but we also
Dominique and now we found out her grand
plan which is just to get her daughter
to be famous oh my god that whole thing
like this I need them to turn it around
I need them to turn this is like like
what a hotel and the soccer player
there's just like so many different
story oh my god the soccer player ID and
obviously his leg is like ruined now
yeah because and he can't play soccer
like I just I don't care about the
Atlantic's I know like the Atlantic's is
still last season and now we have a wine
company Caroline Calloway got a shout
out that was just I texted Jackie I was
like that was crazy I was just like yeah
it was obvious like that was Cristal 3.0
like she's
June no clearly like imagine they said
like Jackie O problem oh my god there's
a million influencer it's just like look
at the Olivia Pope were there ever
evolve Awards yeah born Elizabeth no
literally like it's like that PA didn't
do their research that day no not at
freaking they probably just like came
across the article and they're like ah
just put her in there
yeah like searching this influencer yeah
I'm just really hoping they turn it
around
Riverdale I know you're not caught up
I'm just confused like it's closer I'll
even miss you oh I actually don't know I
saw that you posted that and it's like
are you just trying to ruin it for
everyone no because nobody knows okay so
thanks no we don't not yet
also at the end of season two they make
a team as the at the end of season the
most recent season three I thought it
was they made it seem like something
happened to him so I'm sorry if you if
you're not caught up on that on the last
season I can't help you that's not a
spoiler whoa yeah no don't come for me
saying it's a spoiler because it's fully
not everyone knew that something
happened to Cole at the end of season
three three whatever what happened
remembered and with like last just
Spring Break and everyone's looking for
oh yeah yeah oh I forgot about that and
writing okay cool I need to catch up on
Riverdale but like we have a lot of time
well not in the next two weeks but where
you're taking a family vacation I'm
gonna catch up on everything it's gonna
be we're gonna catch up on family
vacation I don't know like we have a
long fight I'm going to LA like watch no
no not without counselor right anyways
snitch it's been a true joy this is
crazy
you'll be back first night on the toes
eventually but like like wet no no said
sometime you'll be back when if you do
like a show on a Saturday maybe if or if
we did like a podcast only episode right
but in these chairs in these chairs Ohio
we're never that's crazy
we'll see we'll miss you so much we'll
see you tomorrow though yeah and I'll
see you like every day like because
you're my sister and my counselor right
and thank you guys for tuning in we are
the Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time
Claudia we back tomorrow in the meantime
subscribe like this video subscribe to
us on podcast
check out the snatchler new episode
comes out tomorrow
more life updates from you
telling us about where you're at I can't
wait to listen to it it's gonna be
incredible a new episode of date night
with Raven and Adam comes out today so
make sure you subscribe to all of our
TNN shows and make sure to follow me I'm
at 98 K oh my god we gotta go get me
that is her that's her goodbye that's my
parting gift okay but yeah I love you
guys thanks for having me thanks for
being just the best in the bay the
consummate professional true pleasure
and now my watch has ended I'm just like
so [ __ ] depressed I can't and I
shan't and then grant anyways make sure
to follow me as Jackie oh problems so
you can see this jacket in question and
we will see you tomorrow have a great
Monday everyone good luck you'll get
through it
it's almost over it's halfway over so
it's about halfway in 30 minutes
you